shomenuchi need you to show me Jeanne
Kyoto other so this is the less dominant
form here when it come to this position
I'm not able to drive him back and I'm
not even able to feel as elbow coming up
up so ethio is not a possibility for me
at all in this form I'm going to grab
his wrist so I have good control his
hand whose arm this is a good example
where I've been controlling this weapon
hand I'm going to move to the outside of
his body this is the good of heart so
moving to the back side as I moved to
the back side here i'm circling his hand
and locking it up now ideally in this i
want to look it up so tight that he
couldn't come towards me but he's still
able to keep coming as I applied the
details you continue to shove me off of
him this way but as I feel shove I turn
but it wasn't bring him down here again
I dropped an inside we hooking the arm
as I drop here coming across grabbing my
G this hand cuts to the elbow I Drive to
shoulder down up and over one more time
shomenuchi meet your good